[Music]
you're a big Celtics fan I am and you
really get into it
oh I just realized you and I are in the
wrong town I know
diehard yeah yeah and you know I grew up
going to see Celtics the Celtics play
back when they were in the garden back
in the olden times way before your times
and but you I am not like you I kind of
even if I'm watching my team I don't I
don't get crazy I'm kind of an introvert
when I watch my sports team you really
get into it oh yeah and you trash talk
the players you sit on the court and you
trash talk the players I think we have a
picture of you going nuts what's going
on here describe this is what you're
saying here okay so was the game 6
against Orlando Magic and I was trying
to get in their heads and I wanted to
shift us into winning and I was like hey
Vince
are you ready to go back to destiny
rounds and they cotton candy and G
aggressions on Minnie Mouse cuz that's
what you're gonna be no you're not
that's not a good tunt
it's too complicated are you ready to go
to Disneyland because what will happen
tomorrow when you lose and you had a
run-in with Kobe is that right yeah we
were at on a red carpet just before the
all-star game and he comes up and he's
like looking at me like this up and down
I'm like oh what are you doing he's like
oh you know what I'm doing and I'm like
uh no I don't he goes see you're wearing
your green for yourself Dex I'm like
yeah I am and so he's like you know what
I actually really respect you you really
take up for your team and you're not
scared in our territory to show your
love I was like thank you that's nice so
he was cool about it he was cool later
on that have to do with looking you up
it was just you know doing his leg yeah
I know you're wearing your green shirt
for the Celtics cuz I couldn't wear a
Celtics Jersey they wouldn't let me so I
wore you know bright green shirt sure
and whoo and you had a Jew Berlin with
Jack Nicholson the ultimate Lakers fan
yeah well I was at the Lakers game I
think it was like Game six in Los
Angeles
Dane Cook and I were sitting courtside
we like had made it our business our
like second job to go to all these games
and really rally for our team and all of
a sudden we're courtside I'm wearing my
Celtics scared screaming going crazy and
I get booted these guys pull us out a
courtside I'm like what is going on so
we end up in the Chairman's lounge at
halftime and I'm like hiding in this
like hallway and all of a sudden Jack
Nicholson comes out of the bathroom
music hey and I thought really quickly
Mike oh my god what if he he goes I see
they moved your seat he got me kicked
out I heard later you called Jerry buzz
and they had me removed no big li said
bring her to me
he's what they're looking that one bring
her to me
[Applause]